[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans le grand
jt des territoires voici les titres de
l'actualité de cette édition la
martinique teste un nouveau système
dorénavant les passagers de certaines
compagnies aériennes pourront présenter
les résultats de leurs tests qu'ovide
via une application que nous allons
présenter dans ce journal
nous nous rendrons à lyon pour la
journée internationale des droits des
femmes qui a lieu le 8 mars
là aussi un pied de nez vous allez le
voir au co vide puisque une course
individuelle a lieu comment fait-on
vieillir le 20 en corse
eh bien on lit merde sous la mer vont
bien c'est simple corse-matin est allé
regarder de près comment s'y prend ton
si vous êtes une futurs ou jeunes mamans
vous allez découvrir dans ce journal que
vous pouvez fabriquer des bijoux
et oui à partir de votre lait maternel
unique incroyable et vraie un reportage
grandement insolite près de rennes comme
vous venez de l'entendre plusieurs
compagnies aériennes vont tester le
certificat sanitaire numérique sur
certains vols air france air caraïbe et
france billet ont annoncé que les
passagers pourront présenter les
résultats de leurs tests qu'ovide via
une application dès ce mois de mars
les liaisons entre l'hexagone et la
martinique font partie des premiers vols
à tester le dispositif à reportage de la
tv martinique sur place et si bientôt
vous n'auriez plus de papier attendre à
l'embarquement
mais votre téléphone en fin de semaine
dernière air france air caraïbes et
france bis ont annoncé la mise en place
de passes sanitaires sur certains de
leurs vols
une phase de test sur la base du
volontariat le choix des antilles pour
cette expérimentation n'est pas anodin
nous verrons un volume de trafic et qui
conséquente alors que moi puis par
d'émulation montréal sont aujourd'hui
fiable nous sommes donc à verra la
planète même si le nombre de rotations
entre l'hexagone et les antilles a chuté
avec la mise en place des motifs
impérieux les compagnies aériennes table
sur une forte adhésion des passagers
pour que la phase de tests soient
concluantes
en pratique les passagers pourront
télécharger une
fication à oka passe pour air france par
exemple l'application gratuite et
développé en partenariat avec des
laboratoires à l'embarquement il suffira
de la présenter et de faire vérifier son
test qu'ovide via un qr code en moyens
de faciliter et accélérer l'embarquement
pour les compagnies aériennes mais aussi
de sécuriser les résultats des tests
qu'ovide dont les versions papiers
peuvent être facilement falsifiés
si on lance assez pour rassurer nos
clients passent aussi sur les autorités
sur le fait que l'on contrôle
effectivement bien cette semaine
mais bon c'est logique avec le monde
mais quelque part ça rassure les clients
encore une fois c'est assez rapide et
puis on ne peut pas tricher avec ces
tests je vais porter s'inquiéter de la
falsification récurrente de certains
air caraïbes lance son expérimentation
un début mars pour six semaines sur les
vols vers la martinique et la guadeloupe
pour les vols air france à destination
des antilles la phase de test doit
démarrer le 11 mars et durer un mois
voilà il toujours sur le front du coc
vide partons maintenant pour
saint-etienne où les habitants de sade
ils ont de nouveau été appelés à se
faire tester massivement c'était la
deuxième phase de la campagne de
dépistage voulue par l'état et grande
nouveauté c'est dans cette ville qui a
été essayé les tests salivaires avec des
résultats qui arrivent en moins de 20
minutes 12 sites disséminés en ville
mais aussi un bus qui sillonnent les
différents marchés de la ville dans
lequel s'est rendu cécilia et cylia pour
tl7 la télévision de la loire regarder
pour réaliser son test covin ce
stéphanois de donner un peu de sa
personne hamza est acteur de son test
c'est lui qui va réaliser tous les
gestes techniques tout cela supervisé
par une infirmière et pour cela il a
fait spécialement une pause dans sa
journée de travail
c'est pour à pourvoir d'une part celle
de la prévention de deux bancs
pour inciter aussi les gens à aller se
faire de tester et voir ce que ce
problème lors ça n'empêche tous et il
n'est pas le seul à avoir choisi
d'expérimenter la nouvelle technique
le test salivaire jugé moins
traumatisant que le fameux écouvillon
dans le fond du nid non c'est ma femme
qui l'a fait elle m'a dit que c'est
horrible de tous c'est pour ça j'ai déjà
été jusqu'aujourd'hui
quand on m'a expliqué que c'était
vite fait de les faire a bien passé j'ai
ressenti honnêtement en plus choquant on
le fait tout seul c'est mieux que
quelqu'un d'autre il devait les gens
craignent c'est s'était fait désagréable
qu'on ressemble quand on pas avec les
coûts millions le test salivaire serait
tout aussi efficace que le pcr il donne
un résultat en 15 minutes
le patient a juste à suivre un protocole
bien précis
donc on demande aux personnes de yoplait
dont créatrice de comme organisé avec
leur salive dans la bouche en gardant
bien la bouche fermée et après donc de
cracher dans le tube fallait qu'on passe
à la deuxième partie la dalle où on va
demander aux personnes de ce fait relève
eux mêmes dans en introduisant du cours
briand dans une série sur dizaines de
fois ici les stéphanois ont choisi le
bus pour venir se faire tester une
première à l'initiative des élèves
infirmiers de l'ifsi qui ont souhaité
plus de mobilité pour apporter leur aide
dans cette campagne on s'est dit que
leur offrir la possibilité l'opportunité
d'être dépisté à proximité de leur
domicile ou de leur lieu de travail
ça leur permettait de ne pas avoir à
prendre sur leur temps personnel ou sur
leur jour de repos pour aller à voir
cette démarche
bonne nouvelle pour toutes les personnes
testées que nous avons rencontré ce
matin tous été négatifs
mais sur la trentaine réalisé deux se
sont révélés positifs
l'échantillon de salif partira donc au
chu pour une deuxième analyse pour
déterminer la souche du virus
les personnes ont été mises à
l'isolément et puis regardez aussi en
hiver à l'école gabriel péri à saint
martin d'hères un des 17 établissements
pilotes de l'académie de grenoble
les élèves peuvent désormais se faire
dépister grâce à des tests salivaires
aussi là bas une nouvelle technique de
tests beaucoup moins contraignante que
le test nasale comme l'expliquent cette
infirmière scolaire
écoutez c'est indolore donc dans la
seringue il n'y a pas d'aiguillon c'est
une seringue qui est vide
il n'y a aucune ce qui est difficile
pour l'enfant c'est de garder sa bouche
ouverte
un moment et de ne pas avaler sa salive
c'est un réflexe que l'on a et que
l'enfant d'un ter à ce moment là et puis
dans l'oise depuis le 27 février dernier
le port du masque est obligatoire dans
tout l'espace public
les marchés non alimentaires sont
interdits et la préfecture de la somme a
rendu de son côté le port du masque
obligatoire sur toutes les plages du
département pour les personnes de 11 ans
et plus bien jérôme houbron de wéo la
chaîne de la voix du nord est allé
recueillir les propos du maire de fort
mahon plage écoutez vous savoir qu'en ce
moment avec les grandes marées les gens
je suis en groupe quand même l'un à côté
de l'autre sur très peu de sable au
moment de la grande marée c'est à dire
entre midi et 14 heures
donc là c'est vraiment important d'avoir
le port du masque après il est vrai que
quand la mère redescend là il ya
beaucoup plus de place sur la plage
c'est moins évident de mettre le masque
et puis je vous le disais dans les
titres en début de ce journal chaque
année à l'occasion de la journée
internationale des droits des femmes le
8 mars l'association lyonnaise courir
pour elles organisent le lancement de sa
campagne de sensibilisation reprise
ensuite sur les réseaux sociaux
l'occasion de rappeler qu'un de ses
droits et de rester en bonne santé et
que l'activité physique est un moyen de
prévention avant pendant et après un
cancer
le 8 mars est aussi la date du lancement
des inscriptions à la course solidaire
que l'association organise au printemps
coville ou pas cette course est maintenu
les explications de nos partenaires sur
place de lyon capitale tv regarder
depuis 12 ans maintenant l'association
courir pour elle est engagée dans la
lutte contre le cancer
un million six cent mille euros déjà
récolté notamment grâce à l'événement
annuel la course courir pour elles mais
cette année le coït vient jouer les
trouble fête et perturber la campagne
d'inscription
chaque année le 8 mars est un moment
fort pour nous c'est bien sûr la journée
des droits des femmes pour rappeler à
toutes les femmes qu'elles ont le droit
de prendre soin d'elle de prendre soin
de leur santé
cette année encore plus c'est un moment
fort nous ne pourrons pas être place
bellecour par rapport aux contraintes
sanitaires
cela dit c'est un moment important pour
encourager les gens à s'inscrire
femmes et hommes
et rappeler que chaque inscription
permet à courir pour ldd une femme à
l'hôpital
le slogan c'est un dossard vendu une
femme soutenu un dossard acheter une
femme et des 75 % du prix du dossard est
dédié aux missions de courir pour elles
la prévention du cancer par le sport et
le soutien des femmes à l'hôpital en
leur finançant des cours d'activités
physiques adaptées en période de soins
un engagement fort dès lors il était
hors de question d'annuler l'événement
en 2021
grâce à une bonne dose d'imagination et
à la technologie
l'organisation a trouvé le moyen de
faire un pied de nez aux contraintes
sanitaires en proposant une course de
guider le principe c'est de se laisser
guider avec ses écouteurs pendant 5 ou
10 km soit en marchant soit en courant
et tout au long de ce guidage cet
audioguide âge on racontera une histoire
sur pleins d'anecdotes de manière à
rendre enchanteur le parcours a oublié
ses souffrances aussi de sportifs et
puis arrivé sur la ligne d'arrivée avec
le sourire après 5 ou 10 km seule
contrainte indéfectible depuis 12 ans
porter du rose le message est optimiste
fait du sport pour préserver votre santé
et puis notez le un service civique
solidarité seniors se met en place un
service qui répond au double enjeu de
l'isolément des jeunes et des aînés en
privilégiant la solidarité inter
générationnelle
une bien belle idée pour 2000 jeunes qui
dès ce premier semestre
iron t des 45000 personnes âgées isolées
dix mille jeunes supplémentaires d'ici
trois ans aideront 180 mille personnes
seniors ses missions au profit des
seniors seront proposées dans d'autres
régions
ainsi qu'à la réunion j'apprends à
prendre confiance en moi justement
pourra pour échanger avec eux son
remplacent jamais vraiment ses grands
parents mais c'est vrai que ben oui on
dit attachement
on est là tous les jours on les voit
évoluer on échange avec eux ils nous
parlent de leur vie voilà nous nous
rendons en gironde maintenant dans ce
grand jt des territoires où depuis le 18
février les coquillages du bassin
d'arcachon n'ont pas le droit d'être
ramassés ni vendu leur consommation est
interdite par un arrêté préfectoral
si ce n'est pas la première fois que des
problèmes sanitaires sont à l'origine
d'une interdiction
cette fois ci elle est due à la présence
d'un virus celui de la gastro entérite
c'est une première et c'est une
interdiction qui impacte beaucoup les
ostréiculteurs
ils demandent que l'état de catastrophe
naturelle soit déclaré un reportage de
télé7 la chaîne du groupe sud ouest
les résultats sont tombés la semaine
dernière sur les sept prélèvements
d'huîtres du bassin d'arcachon effectués
par les autorités de l'état il ya une
dizaine de jours six contenait des
norovirus le virus responsable de la
gastro entérite en filtrant les
coquillages concentrent les organismes
pathogènes présents dans l'eau c'est la
première fois que celle du bassin
d'arcachon sont touchés par un tel
phénomène
il est à mettre directement en rapport
avec les précipitations de cet hiver en
quelques semaines il est tombé
l'équivalent d'une demi année depuis
début février le réseau d'évacuation
naturelle était saturé les nappes taies
n'a craqué l'eau déborde partout c'est
ce qui est en partie à l'origine de la
présence de ce norovirus dans le bassin
d'arcachon
selon la direction de protection des
populations donc donc je reviens sur ce
terme là de multi et de multi d'origine
effectivement il y aller faut y aller
fort ruissellement et il ya aussi la
saturation des systèmes de d'épuration
qui ne relève pas forcément que du
bassin sensu stricto mais tout le bassin
versant au sens au sens large
la présence de ce virus est certainement
dû à un mélange des eaux de pluie avec
celle user du réseau d'assainissement
il s'est lui aussi retrouvé saturé les
ostréiculteurs du bassin ont porté
plainte une façon pour eux d'obliger
l'état et ses services à faire la
lumière sur cette contamination virale
des eaux du bassin mon origine humaine
ne fait aucun doute pour eux bien sûr
qu'on va se dire c'est pas volontaire
c'est pas quelqu'un qui est complètement
à la masse et qui a décidé de pourrir le
milieu évidemment évidemment que si on
peut apparenter ça un accident
qu'est ce qu'on fait après on en tire
les conséquences et on met des mesures
de gestion en place pour éviter qu'ils
se reproduisent
parce que ce n'est pas acceptable
quelque chose qui relève de la
responsabilité humaine qui d'en faire
une fatalité pour les ostréiculteurs il
faut comprendre l'origine de cet
accident pour qu'ils ne se reproduisent
plus à l'avenir par ailleurs comme il
est lié aux fortes précipitations ils
demandent la reconnaissance de l'état de
catastrophe naturelle
d'autres bassins de production strict
hall en france ont déjà connu une
contamination virale du même type par le
passé
c'est une première sur le bassin
d'arcachon
voilà et cette interdiction de
consommation ne devrait être levé que
dans une dizaine de jours
michel picaud bonjour il n'y a pas d'âge
pour se réinventer vous allez nous
prouver nous ouvrons cette page éco
région avec une entreprise vosgienne qui
fêtera dans quelques temps ses 200 ans
elle fabrique des ustensiles de cuisine
bonjour cyril bonjour a vous tous je
vous emmène au val d'ajol c'est dans les
vosges eux et c'est là où est implanté
depuis 1830 l'entreprise de billets
fabricant d'ustensiles de cuisine
essentiellement pour les professionnels
la manufacture a dû se réinventer
rapidement ces derniers mois face à la
fermeture des restaurants qui lui ont
fait perdre 30% de son chiffre
d'affaires auxquels s'ajoutent les
pertes à l'exportation qui représente
60% de son résultat
alors l'entreprise n'a pas attendu
longtemps pour se réinventer elle
constate qu'en période de confinement
les français sont devenus de faim
pâtissier à la maison faire des gâteaux
pour toute la famille est devenu
tendance et les particuliers se sont
donc rués vers les ustensiles de
pâtisseries à tel point que l'entreprise
a vu son marché pour les particuliers
progresser de 50%
elle a donc réorganiser sa production
pour répondre à la forte demande malgré
une difficulté majeure
l'approvisionnement matières premières
notamment en acier en 2020 l'entreprise
a pu sauver les meubles
enregistrant même une légère croissance
pour 2021 entend reprendre ses
investissements dans les outils de
production
cette histoire nous démontre bien que le
mot rebondir qualifie bien de nombreux
entrepreneurs français qui nous le
démontre chaque jour et ils l'ont nous
permettre certainement de mieux relancer
rapidement la machine économique dans
tous nos territoires
voilà michel picaud merci regardez ces
images qui nous proviennent de corse
on a trouvé un moyen la base de rendre
le vin meilleur en l'immergeant dans la
mer nos partenaires de corse matin nous
ont envoyé ces images en nous précisant
que d'ici un ou deux ans sous l'égide
d'un sommelier qui supervisera un
assemblage très particulier de vin
immergées on obtiendra des saveurs très
spécifiques et uniques
on testera cela pour vous c'est promis
dans un prochain journal est maintenant
dans ce grand jt des territoires nous
allons nous intéresser à la francophonie
le journaliste
migaud a pris les rênes de la fondation
des alliances françaises au printemps
dernier c'est incroyable réseau
d'alliances présent dans 131 pays permet
de continuer à faire vivre la langue et
la culture françaises aux quatre coins
du monde et avec 300 millions de
locuteurs
le français a encore un bel avenir et
continue de rivaliser avec les langues
dominantes notamment grâce à l'afrique
c'est un portrait de ce défenseur d'une
francophonie bien vivante que nous vous
proposons malgré la crise sanitaire avec
christophe frigo pour le grand jt des
territoires regarder son combat pour la
francophonie
yves bigot l'a commencé ici dans les
locaux de tv5 monde
la chaîne de télévision qu'il dirige
mais depuis le printemps dernier le
journaliste et critique musicale préside
la fondation des alliances françaises
véritable navire amiral de la
francophonie qui coordonne les 830 deux
alliances présentes dans 131 pays
une fondation qui a pour mission de
promouvoir la langue et la culture
française à l'étranger mais pas
seulement
il y a quelques années jacques attali
avait rendu un rapport sur la
francophonie justement qui démontrait
que l'on faisait 60 % de plus de
commerces avec des gens dont on parle la
langue et c'est d'ailleurs la raison
pour laquelle des pays comme l'argentine
comme le mexique comme la corée du sud
par exemple ont souhaité rejoindre cette
organisation internationale de la
francophonie et c'est un espace
justement je pense qui permet à ces pays
de sortir de du bloc américain ou du
blog chinois ou de l' influence russe
l'incroyable réseau des alliances
françaises à travers le monde permet
chaque année à plus de 500 milles
personnes d'apprendre le français et à
200 mille candidats de passer des
diplômes d'études en langue française
des alliances fortement impacté par la
crise du coc vite 19 certain nombre
d'alliances sont très grandes
difficultés certaines ont
malheureusement même dû mettre la clé
sous la porte
mais on a réussi à créer aussi cinq
nouvelles alliances dont il ya une très
grande vitalité dans un contexte
évidemment qui est le pire et qui est
épouvantable puisque les élèves dans la
plupart des pays pas 100% mais la grande
majorité ne peuvent plus se rendre en
cours hors les alliances françaises
c'est un lieu non seulement
d'enseignement mais c'est aussi un lieu
de culture
malgré la crise la francophonie reste
bien vivante en 2021
on estime que plus de 300 millions de
personnes par le français
quotidiennement une langue qui progresse
toujours fortement à travers le monde
les chiffres qui sont annoncés pour les
années à venir sont faramineux ils sont
liés à la formidable démographie africa
d'un l'afrique qui est extrêmement
francophone puisque on annonce jusqu'à
700 millions de locuteurs en 2050
aujourd'hui à la cinquième place le
français pourrait même devenir la
troisième langue parlée dans le monde
après l'anglais et le mandarin
voilà est un peu de détente plongeons
nous dans la méditerranée regardez ces
images envoyées par nos partenaires de
la france à l'initiative de
l'association les libres nageurs
nouvellement
et dizaines de personnes se sont mises à
l'eau pour réclamer l'aménagement d'une
piscine publique d'eau de mer à cet
endroit c'est le mois d'août à marseille
vous le voyez quasiment l'honnêteté
quand même qu'à 18 degrés on pourrait
faire une passe in comme ça se fait
d'ailleurs à montréal
à l'intérieur du port l'eau est
suffisamment propre pour que les gens
puissent se baigner
il ya des véritables aménagements il ya
des maîtres nageurs il ya tout ce qu'il
faut pour que les gens puissent se
baigner on dans de bonnes conditions
et puis en occitanie regarder ce que nos
partenaires de la dépêche
eux nous ont envoyé comme image c'est la
violette de toulouse que vous voyez
actuellement qui fleurit de janvier au
mois de mars
hélène vié la fondatrice de la maison de
la violette dans le quartier historique
des maraîchers à la lande est au micro
de manon aussi pour nous faire découvrir
cette petite fleur rare en pleine
floraison écoutez c'est la pleine
floraison ça va durer quelques semaines
et apparaissent énormément de fleurs et
beaucoup de beaucoup de boutons donc ça
va encore fleurir pendant un mois c'est
très parfumée c'est une période
extraordinaire
les fleurs on les cueille une à une à la
main et puis dans les titres vous avez
trouvé cela incroyable moi aussi ce
reportage va intéresser les jeunes
mamans ou les futurs jeunes mamans
cette créatrice que vous allez voir est
installé du côté de rennes en bretagne
et travaille en effet le lait maternel
pour créer des bijoux des bijoux qui de
ce fait sont totalement unique est pour
le moins insolite dont est allé se
parent et raphaël ton driot gauthier
pour tvr à rennes regardez depuis mai
2000 20 cette mère de trois enfants
travaille le lait maternel pour créer
des souvenirs sur mesure destinés aux
mamans faut faire attention parce que ma
de basses est un liquide vivent donc il
ya un protocole très strict à faire dès
l'arrivée du lait maternel à l'atelier
en fait pour permettre
pour lui permettre de garder sa couleur
entre autres son déclare enfin le but
c'est vraiment que ça soit un bijou qui
a une durée de vie illimitée qui se
gardent toute la vie perle coeur avec ou
sans inclusion de mèches de cheveux
chaque bijou est unique
pour cela les clients doivent envoyer 3
fioles de leur propre lait maternel
la recette pour solidifier le lait
restent secrètes
mais il faut compter six à huit semaines
pour réaliser ses commandes pour les
mères c'est une manière insolite de
garder une trace de l'allaitement
ça représente ce lien qu'elles ont eues
avec leur bébé
cette fusion un peu c'est un lien fort
l'allaitement c'est quand même un bon
deux soirs c'est naturel mais ça reste
un don de la maman du meilleur qu'elle
puisse donner à son bébé donc
aujourd'hui hélène confectionne entre 60
et 80 bijoux par mois des produits qui
sont ensuite envoyées dans toute la
france mais aussi outre atlantique
comptez entre 35 et 100 euros pour se
souvenir unique en son genre
voilà un reportage à coup sûr pour les
jeunes mamans
et puis du côté de la nouvelle aquitaine
regarder comment on découvre deux jeunes
artistes graphistes peintres
photographes locaux par le biais de
l'affichage public à limoges la totalité
du réseau réservé habituellement à la
communication municipale offre en ce
moment une exposition dans toute la
ville comme vous le voyez sur ces images
d'alain druot de 7 à limoges
alors quand on ne peut pas aller à des
expositions par ses tantes qu'ovide et
bien les expositions viennent à vous en
tout cas à limoges je suis tombé sur un
panneau le premier panneau que j'ai vu
c'était mes photos et
très sûr pays actuellement les photos de
nicolas oui oui j'en ai vu là tout à
l'heure où en descendant il y en a
c'est de l'émotion ça fait plaisir on
sent un peu reconnu et puis ça fait du
bien
voir des images qui sont pas de la
publicité et vous avez-vous changé vos
habitudes de consommation depuis un an
eh bien c'est la question que nous nous
sommes posée aujourd'hui alors pour y
répondre nous avons frappé aux portes
d'un magasin bien connue spécialisée
dans la vente d'équipements
électroménagers et de multimédia et vous
allez voir que nous avons eu raison nous
interroger le portage est signée
frédéric lamy pour tlc à chaud les
regarder non contente d'avoir mis la
planète bleue à ses genoux
lakovic 19 peut se targuer en plus
d'avoir modifié nos habitudes d'achat le
secteur des produits bruns à l'image des
télévisions des produits audio et plus
largement de l'électroménager en est le
parfait exemple c'est ce que l'on
pourrait appeler l'effet papillon il ya
une évolution de la consommation des
ménages et notamment des choletais
beaucoup de dépenses qu'il faisait au
quotidien ne se font plus les gens ne
peuvent plus aller au cinéma
les gens ne peuvent plus aller faire du
sport légende de fleurs et surtout aller
au restaurant
donc en fait toute cette épargne
aujourd'hui ben s'est fait sur des
achats de consommation comme la télé
mais aussi les ordinateurs tous les
secteurs
[Musique]
exploser les chiffres ont doublé nous a
confié le représentant du magasin qui
pensait au départ a une tendance
éphémère liés à la réouverture des
magasins le 11 mai dernier
mais ce qui n'était pas parti pour durer
c'est finalement inscrire dans la durée
conséquence pour le magasin il est
parfois difficile de répondre à toutes
les demandes des clients avec les
répercussions de la crise sanitaire sur
les usines de production on est en train
de payer le premier confinement où
toutes les usines de production et en
était à l'arrêt et vous rajoutez à ça
une pénurie en plus sur des semelles et
est ce qu'on appelle les semi
conducteurs c'est les petits composants
électroniques et bien les fabricants ont
été ont eu beaucoup de difficultés à
nous approvisionner malheureusement je
crains que là on revienne entre
guillemets à la normale peut-être à
l'été voire à la rentrée prochaine
si la patience est un terme très à la
mode free de la crise sanitaire
un autre du vol peut être la vedette
c'est le mot adaptabilité et pour cause
tous les citoyens du globe doivent
depuis un an s'accommoder impossible de
faire autrement et c'est ce à quoi a été
soumis ce magasin comme bien d'autres
c'est aujourd'hui le drive dans nos
métiers il ya encore un an ça n'existait
pas on avait ce qu'on appelait du click
and collect c'est à dire je commande sur
internet et je viens chercher en magasin
or là le magasin était fermé et j'ajoute
l'expérience a été une première et le
dispositif a été logiquement maintenu la
demande est en très forte encore à ce
niveau là dans la mesure où les clients
n'ont plus besoin de rentrer dans le
magasin
voilà et puis pour finir ce journal
quelques images du sud de la france
regardez c'est un lieu où la population
de la principauté de monaco a l'habitude
de se réunir tous les matins le marché
de la condamine tente de retrouver une
vie normale depuis le début de la
pandémie
ce sont des images de vanessa des six de
monaco info qui nous font présager que
tout redeviendra bientôt normal du moins
on l'espère tous en tout cas c'est le
voeu de cette fin deux grands jt des
territoires merci de nous avoir suivis
rendez vous dans une prochaine édition
sur tv5monde et sur vos chaînes locales
et régionales
bon
à tous au revoir
[Musique]